hey there I'm Conan O'Brien welcome to
serious jibber-jabber
I'm here with best-selling author Evan
Thomas whose latest book being Nixon a
man divided provides a compelling
psychological portrait of the 37th
President of the United States after
reading this book just about two weeks
ago I feel for the first time that I
might understand Richard Nixon and
that's really saying something
Evan thanks for being here this book is
fantastic thank you so much to talk
about I will tell you my experience with
Nixon I was quite young when he was
president but when I came of age as a
comedy writer the comedy writers that
were older than me who had been comedy
writers in the 60s and 70s they they
just thought of Nixon as the ultimate
figure of fun yeah you know and I think
that was the way most of the
intelligentsia thought of him most
pundits most entertainers Richard Nixon
was Darth Vader yeah and also one of a
comical character to them then I read
this book and see him as a person and
there's a lot of pathos there's a lot of
I've read the book feeling like I wish
someone could have helped this guy
because he had such tremendous promise
and it feels to me like you have a lot
of sympathy for Richard I do I mean I
shared the cartoon version going into
this I work for the Washington Post
Company mm-hmm Watergate that's the
people who got never heard of that I
didn't get to that part of the book I'm
told I'm told everything ends well
that's what I'm told to terms he goes
out on top I'm not sure it's a tragedy
but it ends badly yeah and the
Washington Post get some yep and that's
the world I grew up in journalism I used
to the owner Katharine Graham used to
have these dinner parties and I was
working for and I would go to them and
if those dinner parties in Georgetown
people would make fun of Nixon and I
shared that that view that Nixon was
kind of an ogre
or a figure of ridicule and there are
some ridiculous things about Nixon and
he did some pretty dark things good but
he was a human being obviously but but
he's a poignant figure to me too
of somebody who tried to be someone that
he really couldn't be but he did try
what's fascinating you start the book
with this is and what I really love
about the book is that it it's not an
academic exercise you are telling
stories about a person true stories
about a person that I haven't heard
about Nixon before that give you an
insight into who a facet of his
character who he is and one of the
things that's early in the book is you
talk about Nixon loved movies loved
movies and he's president and he's in
the White House and he compulsively
watched movies and he'd watch anything
and famously he loved the movie Patton
and everybody knows that you say around
the world in 80 days was his favorite
movie favorite movie around the world in
80 days a light comedy about a British
travelling gentleman who knew yeah I
love little tidbits like that but you
have this and this this anecdote which I
think came from someone in his family
that that maybe one of his daughters
that Richard Nixon no matter how bad the
movie was people would start to say okay
this is a this is a bomb let's get out
of here let's leave and it's the White
House theater so we can go we didn't pay
any money let's get out of here Nixon is
always saying hang on hang on
it's gonna get better wait wait it'll
get better wait wait it'll get better
it'll get better and that is a
touchstone for you that's a way into his
character which is Nixon it's crazy he
was do you say a man divided I see an
incredible pessimist an incredibly dark
self-defeating pessimist
who's relentlessly optimistic somehow at
the same time is that is right is yes
I mean it's dizzying yes he would come
home at night I got this from Julie his
daughter Julie might have an oral
history and she would describe Nixon
coming home at night he would come in
the door whistling upbeat whistle he
would turn on all the lights he would
put a showtune on the record player when
they had dinner was all to be happy
upbeat optimistic talk now that night he
might have a couple of pops and be down
in the dumps and brood but he wanted to
be an optimistic person he was
constantly trying to either talk about
bucking up the troops he wanted to buck
up the troops yeah and he was constantly
doing that to his subordinates he was
actually for a kind of a weird and
volatile guy good to work for he was
good to the his staff mm-hmm and he
wanted to make them feel better about
themselves and about him he could not
sustain this you know he would lash out
he would say vile things people your
your your viewers have listened to the
tapes we all have yeah he would make any
Semitic remarks I mean his terabyte but
he wanted to be a happier person he
could not sustain it but he wanted to be
that person
he's got VZ let yellow legal pads I
don't think most Americans know this
about him but he always had these legal
pads and at night he would go over the
executive what was it called the gob the
EO I could have office okay executive
office willing that's right and hid you
know sit in a big recliner with his
legal patter hood go into a study in the
Lincoln off the Lincoln Bedroom or
something and he would sit there and he
would write out these kind of self-help
slogans compulsively yeah leadership I
mean about you know
upbeat a man of action joyful that was
my favorite one he wanted you not we do
not associate Richard Nixon with the
word joy also that he used that yeah who
writes almost like they're doing
homework on a legal pad I will be joyful
that is not the essence of being joyful
and to me I read the book and I felt a
sadness for him and some people watching
now may say how can you say you felt
sorry for Richard Nixon and he's like
because you have to know and through
this book you do you have to know what
he grew up in what he came from which
was terribly depressing and sad I mean
his whole life and I didn't know this
until I read your book his whole life he
lived in fear he
and admired anyone who went to Harvard
those Harvard types those Harvard I hate
them but I also in Kennedy went to
Harvard I didn't know and you it's in
the book that he had an opportunity to
go to Harvard yeah well he would say is
easy no more Harvard bastards in my
cabinet right but here's the thing about
Nixon and he didn't say there's just a
few times again and again no and he
would get to staff going on but a couple
of things one has he got into Harvard
himself and couldn't go there cuz he
made money he had a scholarship or would
have gotten the scholarship but no money
even to physically get there yeah but
also he hired he said no more Harvard
bastards and then he hired them his
chief National Security Advisor Henry
Kissinger is a Harvard professor yep his
chief domestic adviser Daniel Patrick
Moynihan is a Harvard professor it's
confusing because Nixon with Nixon is
Attorney General John Mitchell used to
say watch what we do not what we say
that's very true and Nixon Nixon would
rant about Harvard and then he'd go out
and hire Harvard but professor Nixon
would say I I hate intellectuals I I
like to talk to athletes intellectuals
are feminine but Nixon himself was a bad
athlete and he was an intellectual yeah
he was deeply well-read he I asked to
see Nixon's private library which is out
at the Nixon Library political
philosophy philosophers political
biography underlined just like in
college little stars and all that he was
much most politicians don't read
anything no they can barely read they're
talking points right and Nixon because
he was lonely and weird and didn't like
talking to people spent hours and hours
deeply reading into political philosophy
his whole life is him acting opposite to
his nature acting completely opposite to
his nature he is shy he is not he is not
a glad-hander what does he do he wants
to get into he wants to jump into
politics and shake everybody's hand he
doesn't want to but he puts himself in a
position where that's what he has to do
he was I like him to somebody it was
afraid of heights so he dives off cliffs
mm-hmm I mean he loved the I think he
got a free saw of excitement by
challenging
the very things he fear to do for
instance going into crowds she's a shy
boy like to plunge into crabs angry
crowds and he had this expression that
was famous when he put his hands out he
got that from Dwight Eisenhower
President Eisenhower who got actually
got from Churchill that's so it's a
world war two things be factory but by
the late sixties the V sign means peace
the peace Nick so Nixon loved to go out
to the peaceniks and the peace
demonstrators who were throwing things
at him throwing things out I mean do
that and he said early drives him crazy
yeah you like to taunt crowds and and to
have an crowd almost killed him in 1958
he's in Caracas Venezuela yep and he's
vice president vice president United
States an angry mob starts rocking his
car and they smashed the windows and the
Secret Service guy next time pulls out a
pistol and says I'm gonna shoot some of
those SOPs and Nixon says put away your
gun only if they come into the car and
drag me out to do shoot him so he was
physically brave and I think he liked to
have his courage tested his me while I
was about to say his moral courage
that's that's a more complicated subject
but but he liked to be he liked to test
himself he was compelled to go this is
unlike many politicians compelled to go
where he would most not be wanted right
so there's that famous scene that you
depict in the book where he just can't
sleep he's up all night there's a big
demonstration in Washington if you can't
imagine a modern president doing this he
gets up you know in the wee hours of the
morning and goes to the Lincoln Memorial
and starts trying to connect personally
with protesters who were staying up all
night disaster and it goes badly because
he just doesn't know how to do it but
his you can see his intention is I just
want to go talk to these kids and bridge
the gap right and bridge the gap and
relate to them but you start talking
about Winston Churchill they don't even
know who Winston Churchill is and
neither sleepy stone kids it's five
o'clock in the morning they've driven
all the way to Washington they probably
think they're on it they're having an
acid trip or they can't believe ya
Richard Nixon is there there's the
president United States standing there
with this Manolo his button to see what
services far away at the Lincoln
Memorial and you know then Nixon tries
to
late to them by talking about football
and surfing and so of course they make
fun of him later with the reporters and
it's just it's kind of heartbreaking
that Nixon wanted to reach out and talk
about the meaning of life to these kids
and they who is a strange guy it just
didn't work he is physically very
awkward to a almost like I said
Inspector Clouseau kind of Leary you
have all these great anecdotes of him
going to sign an important piece a
document but he can't get the pen off
but then he tries to put the kid the cap
off and then he puts I put it back on
but stabs himself and then gets ink on
the document and you really do feel like
it's a it's a Peter Sellers routine well
he had you know one of the things that
the President does was to pin medals on
war heroes but Nixon kept stabbing the
recipient with the pin so Brent
Scowcroft told me his military aid that
he gets special velcro medals so that he
could just put velcro on yeah and the
thing about the tapes the famous tapes
yeah they were voice automated
automatically went on why because he
couldn't figure out the buttons he
couldn't turn on his own tape he
couldn't open an aspirin bottle he
couldn't use a dictaphone he just
couldn't do any of that stuff so the
tapes were voice activated and they
heard everything that they heard
everything you talk about his hands his
hands kind of fine and spun spun a lot
and go yeah he couldn't talk he was just
he was literally speechless this is a
guy a politician it gives hundreds of
speeches a year and it goes into crowds
and has to now he did have one thing
which I envy he had a good memory could
remember names and he was shy but he
could remember your name and he would
keep it was relentlessly prepared he
would write on index notes you know
Conan O'Brien brother of right you know
son of mine says goddamn Harvard you
know right you know he write all this
data so that when he met you he spit it
all back to you and you were impressed
by it and that overcame it compensated
for and really overcame his kind of
essential shyness so he's like I say
he's he's trying very hard to do what
does not come in his nature
at all and it's like he's almost
physically limited he's he sees pictures
of Jack Kennedy or Bobby Kennedy walking
on the beach and he decides I'll do that
too to show the press and the press are
all lined up and he's in I think maybe
San Clemente and he's gonna walk along
the beach but he's wearing black socks
and black shoes and this becomes the
essence of what people thought about him
is that he just couldn't do it
right and there's no one around him to
say take your shoes off right walk bare
it was cold I mean you know yeah yeah it
was January there's always a reason yeah
it was a reason but he was sure not Jack
Kennedy and he was never gonna be Jack
Kennedy right weirdly they were friends
well this is what I was gonna get to
next and thank you for getting us there
do you have some anecdotes in here again
I didn't know they both start in
Congress they're both fought in the war
and they're both part of this surge of
young servicemen coming back and getting
elected in 46 to to Congress and so
they're in the same Congress together
and they get to know each other and you
tell this story of them riding a train
sharing a train car together and upper
berth and a lower berth and hanging out
like these two pals which is
mind-blowing to think about yeah I mean
when you consider what came later but
they they're about the same age they're
vets and this was interesting Nixon
sense Tim Kennedy a kindred shyness for
all of his glamour Jack Kennedy actually
was a bit of a loner himself and shy and
diffident it was charming it was catnip
fertile for women but it was Nixon
related to that now Nixon was going
after they met Nixon went to Europe on a
fact-finding trip and Kennedy of course
gave him the names of three girls Paris
look up look up I love that story yeah
yeah Nixon's often and you know that
Nixon has no interest in he that's the
furthest thing from his mind and and
just this idea of JFK saying why you
know as I look up these girls they're
good girls but there's that and there's
also Kennedy when he was a senator
you know he had this terrible back
ailment he's got Addison's disease he's
in the hospital and he's near death and
I thought this was stunning eyes Nixon
visits him in the hospital and when he
walked out of the hospital room his
weeping he's crying he's crying crying
because he's afraid jack is gonna die
yeah they were they were that close
you don't think of Nixon as being a
crier or sentimental but there he was
weeping over over Jack Kennedy who mean
generally like until he ran against them
for president then that's a different
whole different picture that doesn't
make for friends anyways when you run
against somebody for president but the
contrast between them of course become
highlighted many of us remember the day
the first great presidential debate
right Nixon against Kennedy Kennedy's
tanned and handsome and cool and Nixon
sweating through his makeup and even the
makeup story is one of these cruel
stories because before the debate there
was early days of TV first big
presidential debate and the makeup guy
comes around and says the candidate you
want makeup and it Kennedy says no then
he goes back to the to his green room
and gets maxfactor fancy makeup Kennedy
right he said in front of Nixon I don't
need no new makeup so so but then he got
he went off privately and got makeup
exactly you know Nixon they asked Nixon
do you want makeup it's the Nixon says
no because he saw Kennedy so Kennedy say
no so then he goes and one of his aides
goes down to Michigan Avenue and gets
some hideous thing called shave stick
which is this grease that they rub on
his five o'clock shadow and if you watch
that you can google this and walk out on
YouTube Nixon is sweating through his
shave stick and Kennedy is all looking
at all cool I mean Nixon prepared for
the debate by studying briefing books
kennedy prepared by listening to Peggy
Lee records and taking a nap yeah and it
was just this one guy's graceful and
easy the other guy's struggling and
striving and of course the American
people could see this and they maybe
should have felt sorry for Nixon but
they didn't no one wants to feel sorry
for their leader yeah right and you know
there's also a thing I didn't know which
is that Nixon had injured himself it was
in pain during was a pistol
one of the debates he had and he had an
injury so he's actually and then John
the way he so he already has an injury
to his knee his knee was so clumsy that
getting out of a car he smashed his knee
and of course luck would have it he got
gets infected gets infected and then he
clobbers the knee on the day of the
debate so he's he's in physical pain
he's lost ten pounds from working too
hard so his shirt-collar is loose around
his neck he looks like hell and even
though if you listen to the debate on
radio Nixon won
no not Kennedy but if you watched it
Kennedy won yeah and also what they were
by today's standards what they were
arguing over there you have a very
centrist Democrat and very centrist
Republican they essentially disagree
about very little not today we have the
these social issues and these these
massive divides between what people
think the spear the Republican Party and
the spirit of the Democratic Party and
back then no man they're essentially
they're essentially the same right
there's no different there's no
difference in their policies you know
Kennedy's on the future young new you
know let's move forward all he's got a
vague bromides right not moving forward
Nixon who had been vice president for
Eisenhower as the past wasn't so bad
fifties weren't really pretty good so
there's that kind of generational thing
or not but substantively not not really
difference okay you you mentioned
Eisenhower so we should we should talk
about that
Nixon Revere's Eisenhower Eisenhower's
the great man you know the the the man
who led us through World War two
conquered Europe conquered Europe d-day
made all the big calls then a two-term
president during this great period of
stability and wealth and Nixon is a very
young vice president and it seems like
this is a great this should be a great
relationship it wasn't Nixon and
Eisenhower it did not have the
relationship that Nixon wanted no
because well Nixon's because he's
maladroit walks into he meets Nixon who
had been lieutenant JG in World War two
Eisenhower had been
five star general Nixon walks in the
first thing he says is hi chief
yeah and you didn't say hi chief the
Eisenhower so right away because the
next was just feeling awkward he's a
blurter you know like I do there's a
cocktail parties I don't know what to
say hi chief right and so right away
they got foot then Eisenhower tries to
dump Nixon from the ticket because of
the so-called fun scandal right that's
when Nixon gives us famous checkers
speech Nixon's all along the president
the the the presidential candidate and
all his smart buddies want to dump Nix
Eisenhower really let Nixon hang out to
dry during that whole scandal in a way
that even by today's standards seems
very cold cold I mean if you've been
supreme Allied commander you're a cold
guy I don't care how warm your smile is
you've sent thousands of men to die yeah
and Eisenhower done that he didn't give
a damn about Richard Nixon and he showed
it and so Nixon's hung out to dry there
Nixon has to save himself by going on TV
he's terrible at TV but he figured out
he gave up and you can google it again
why write the checkers speech he gave
what would seem like a sentimental
mawkish speech to us sophisticates but
to a lot of Americans actually was quite
moving a little guy you know was being
kind of dumped by that by by the
insiders and so all the cool crowd sort
of looked at and said always being live
but most Americans sympathized with
Nixon and they flooded telegrams and
Nixon stayed on the ticket and he
survived but eyes never tried to dump
him again in 1956 yeah the story goes on
well that's something that comes out is
that he does have these skills we've
talked a lot about what he couldn't do
but Nixon had this incredible instinct
for what would play with people right
and what and what and and the checkers
speech is an example of the Georgetown
crowd the New York crowd they all the
people that Nixon you know he didn't
like them they didn't like Nixon they
all watch the speech and you see echoes
of it today where we have these
candidates and you know
Trump comes up and all of us are
thinking yeah who is this clown this is
crazy yeah well what are we talking
about here and but clearly you know
there is a large portion of the country
that is being spoken to that feels
otherwise ignored and Nixon had that
ability to to hit that tone he came up
with this concept of the silent majority
well he didn't he didn't just come up
with him as president when he's a
college student he gets the Whittier
College yeah and of course there's a
cool guys fraternity the Franklin's yeah
they're the cool yeah so Nixon starts a
paternity for uncool guys because there
are more of them early political
perception side with the Outsiders
against the insiders if you want to get
to 51% if you want to get a majority the
silence when the silent majority that's
a phrase he uses in a speech of 1969 but
he gets the idea at nineteen thirty at
Whittier College he runs for student
body president basically against the
cool guys against the insiders against
the establishment he never stopped doing
that and he was good at it in 1972
Richard Nixon is hopelessly shy guy wins
one of the greatest landslides in
history he destroys George McGovern wins
every state except for Massachusetts and
this is an important part he wins thirty
five percent of the Democratic vote you
know thirty five percent of Democrats
how did he do that he was good at
peeling away Democrats who were
disaffected with the eastern
establishment with the New York Times
with the network's with Harvard with
Wall Street he peels all those folks
around the outsiders because he stands
for them they sense that he's on their
side against the elites that's exactly
what's happening now and in our politics
it's all become running against those
guys have been running things I'm an
outsider like you and what's amazing is
Nixon's doing it as someone who's been a
two-term right vice president and then a
elected president the total insider
he's a total insider he's the ultimate
insider but he he felt very powerfully
that he was an outsider he could convey
that he did and and people sense that
even if he's awkward and weird
and kind of sweaty they sense this
something about him enough voters they
don't love him he's not a popular figure
right right he doesn't really move
people he doesn't even move people like
Donald Trump he doesn't have Trump's
confidence yeah but they sense that he
is gonna look after their interests and
that was not wrong he he did look after
their interests and he was good at
playing on that he was he was good at
playing on their fears that's the sort
of not good part of it but that is part
of populism is playing upon people's
fears and prejudices and he was
fantastically successful I mean they say
that Reagan is the father of the modern
Republican Party Nixon was those Reagan
Democrats you know though disaffected
Democrats Nixon got them first in fact
he got them in greater numbers than
Reagan did Republicans don't like to
admit this because Nixon's an unsavory
character and it's confusing
you'll never seen Fox News say that
Nixon is the father of the Republican
Party even though the head of Fox News
Roger Ailes help make Nixon in 1968 but
that's too complicated that story's too
cops not a good narrative not a good
narrative
ok well this brings up another point
that is fascinating that Nixon is
despite everything that you would think
about him because he's a Republican and
he's thought of as as I said this this
dark figure and this conservative and
you know very much this more or less
evil character responsible for a lot of
liberal yeah legislation a lot and I was
thinking by voting rights I was I listed
them Environmental Protection Agency
OSHA Amtrak Civil Rights Medicare Social
Security funding he tried to get
something like Obamacare passed in a in
an initial form he was not the
Republican that probably most Republican
candidates and that most Republicans
wanted he was not the candidate that
they really wanted he was quite quite
liberal yeah I mean one thing is
Republicans are different those days
there were such a thing as moderate
northeastern moderate Republicans a
species that no longer exists
George HW Bush would be a model of that
those people don't exist anymore right
but but Nixon's confusing because he his
rhetoric was conservative but again you
have to watch what he actually did yeah
Nixon was president in a liberal era the
early 1970s or a liberal era mm-hmm
Congress was controlled by Democrats by
mostly Liberal Democrats Nixon could
have just been oppositional and said I'm
not dealing with you but didn't he made
deals he liked to make deals no and he
liked to confound his enemies he liked
to outflank them outsmart them in the
environments a good example the
environmental movement is just getting
going in the late 60s and it's champion
as a guy named Edmund muskie who was a
senator Democratic senator from Maine
and Nixon thinks that muskie could be
the Democratic candidate in 1972 and so
hmm Nixon says I'm gonna outflank this
guy so that's how we got the
Environmental Protection Agency Nixon
moved to look really the left of muskie
to steal his thunder and then of course
if the signing of the clean air clean
water acts Nixon who could be petty
refused to even invite muskie to the
signing of it just a kind of thumb as
knows Adam Wright Nixon you know could
be vindictive but but the point is he's
constantly maneuvering politically he
likes deals he puts together these
floating coalition's he's kind of hard
to peg he's situational he knows he's in
a liberal era so he's got a kind of play
by the ball there and it's confusing
historians get confused by Nixon they
some people call him a liberal some
people oh no no no no girl he was
conservative
he was an odd amalgam a lot of negatives
but he got things done well what's very
interesting to me is everybody knows if
you listen to the Watergate tapes if you
listen to him in office he sounds
anti-semitic yeah he sounds he's sound
and he's yeah the anti-semitic racist
but what's interesting is that Israel
it's possible Israel's never had a
better friend than Richard Nixon and so
it's very strange and and he's you know
he's hires a lot of Jewish you know
people to to work for him he can also
you know there's this racism that that
is it sounds so vile when he's talking
about it but then he tries to do a lot
and does do a line does do a lot for
african-americans and so the whole thing
when you say a man divided it really
goes through every strata but really
does everything is half this half that I
say this but I do that and I do that but
I say this well he was like a lot of us
he was insecure only more so knits and a
lot of politicians are like the rest of
us only more so
mm-hmm and Nixon had this ambivalence
and he was a blurter he blurted stuff
out and so he would blurt out terrible
things about Jews you know I would make
these anti-semitic right so you listen
to them on the tapes and you cringe they
are you can't now can't gloss it over
there it's ugly but he saves Israel 1974
Yom Kippur War Israel is reeling under
Egyptian and Syrian attack the Arabists
at the State Department and that the
Defense Department really don't want to
save Israel is Nixon the president says
send every airplane yeah send it all and
he was regarded in Israel as a savior
one of his best buddies was gold in my
ear the Prime Minister of Israel was
very close to Nixon
how do you reconcile that with Nixon's
eighties cynical remarks you can't you
know you know Nixon's closest foreign
policy aide and because it was Jewish
head of the Federal Reserve Arthur burns
Jewish chief speech one of his chief
speechwriter is sapphire Jewish you know
yeah there's something almost
schizophrenic about it the let's talk
about the people around Nixon the people
he surrounded himself with the people
that he and it's interesting because he
Kissinger is a great example of someone
who he very much understands and admires
Henry Kissinger and wants him in his
corner but also is aware that Kissinger
may not always
working in his best interest Kissinger
comes across as an insecure guy
Nixon's insecure Kissinger is a star and
Nixon's wary of it but but many times
Nixon could have ejected Kissinger but
he doesn't right so there's a it's a
wonderful awful relationship they do
great things together
they go to China they negotiate an arms
control deal with the Soviet Union Nixon
is the first president to go to Moscow
they really they start the Middle East
peace process
you know Kissinger deserves great credit
for that but meanwhile they're caught in
this high school one-upsmanship and
Kissinger to his discredit is selling
out Nixon at these fancy dinner parties
in Georgia Nixon used Kissinger to be
kind of an ambassador to Georgetown to
the smarts because he was accepted
Kissinger was accepted charming and he
would go to Catherine Graham's house
here we go anyway I've seen him there I
mean he was he was funny he was
self-deprecating self-deprecating charm
Nixon had none yeah so that's great
except that Kissinger starts to sell out
Nixon at these dinner parties he starts
making fun of the President and of
course it gets back to Nixon of course
it does and Nixon tries to be
philosophical about it and says well
it's for enemies ego I I have no you go
I don't worry about this but you know we
have to be nice to Kissinger any Woods
and when Kissinger would leave in the
evening because Nixon would say well
there goes Henry to see his friends in
Georgetown or there goes Henry to talk
to the leak to the Washington Post and
he tried to make a joke of that sort of
bad joke of it yeah but I've heard and
the famous tapes the we've heard so much
about they are installed two years into
Nixon's term because of Kissinger
Kissinger is going around town saying
all the good ideas are his idea I hate
going to China that's all me and Nixon
was mad because it actually wasn't the
truth going to China was not Kissinger's
idea it was Nixon's idea in fact when
they tell Kissinger the Nixon's thinking
of going to China Kissinger said fat
chance right we're not doing it so so
Nixon is jealous and he's aggrieved and
he wants our record
he puts that taping system in so there's
a record of what actually gets said in
the Oval Office so that when they're
writing their memoirs
they'll have real proof yes yeah it is
Shakespearean he he puts the taping
system in that hangs him yeah thanks the
so he's got these people he's got
Haldeman he's got Ehrlichman and what's
interesting is I always think of Nixon
is an incredibly tough guy and in his
way he was tough but what comes out in
the book is that he is pathologically
non confrontational he does not want to
confront anybody so this guy who can
order these Christmas bombings this guy
that can in on these tapes lash out in
this very violent way doesn't want to
confront anybody right and that is a
real weakness - it sure is and it gets
him in a big trouble in Watergate
because Watergate is seen as this
massive conspiracy to right disrupt the
Constitution and Watergate was bad they
did they did do illegal bad stuff but
their real problem was that Nixon could
not confront his own subordinates he
didn't know about the Watergate break-in
he didn't know about the break-in -
Ellsberg psychiatrist office he didn't
know about these Washington Horrors as
Mitchell called them but he engages in a
cover-up because he cannot bring himself
to get everybody into one room and say
what the hell what the hell is going on
and do something about it he finally
does nine months after the break-in
there's sort of a meeting it's a kind of
a bogus meeting right nothing really
happens it's too late it's too late
Nixon is on his way down well he's you
know the what did fuel the Watergate
break-in and what fuel a lot of Nixon's
problems is that he'd get very dark and
he'd get very vindictive as he said and
he would throw out ideas and what he
really needed what I when I read the
book I thought what he needed was people
around him to say what are you talking
about you're you're going to China
you're going to Russia you're you're
about to win a landslide second term
what are you talking about knock it off
he would throw out these crazy ideas and
there were people around him who
say hey wait a minute I know a guy who
could take care of this yes that's it
when when he he's enabled a little bit
by people that are listening to him when
sometimes he didn't expect anybody
seriously even that thought yes but even
that's complicated because Haldeman and
Ehrlichman is to the the Berlin Wall as
they were called yeah there's a lot of
evidence of them not caring at Nixon's
orders of them knowing not this is a
crazy board by the boss we're not gonna
do it right
Haldeman buried all sorts of nutty Nixon
orders Kissinger told me a time when
Nixon got drunk and told him to bomb
Damascus and he just waited until Nixon
woke up and sobered up you know so when
he told him what's interesting is when
he told I think when he told Nixon I
didn't do that
Nixon be like oh good good oh good right
I understood that I just had too many
drinks right yes but of course people
get exhausted and after four years
Nixon's ranting it had a kind of
corrosive effect the kind of poisonous
effect if you do this for long enough
even if your aides try to save you from
yourself they get worn down and of
course the junior aides don't quite
understand that the next level down from
Haldeman and Ehrlichman John Dean that
the kind of next junior level they think
Nick Sammy's it he's the president he's
the president yeah and I mean one of the
things that happened this gets a little
complicated but for years the FBI used
to do the dirty work of presidents Jake
or Hoover remember him there's a bad guy
yeah and he would blackmail presidents
and also do their dirty work right but
by about 1970 Hoover can feel the wind
is shifting and you know people are
suing the FBI for illegal bugging the
war in court court the liberal Supreme
Court had suddenly discovered the Bill
of Rights and the Fourth Amendment and
Hoover goes you know I am getting out of
this business
he gets the FBI out of the spying for
the president business so Nixon has to
go in house and they create the plumbers
who are the plumbers Hunt and Liddy who
sound good on paper CIA FBI but they're
actually kind of losers they're
goofballs they're goofball
and they've been dumped in the great
bureaucratic tradition the CIA dumped
hunt on the White House to get rid of
him not to promote it's really funny is
that hunt they want to get rid of hunt
CIA and the litt and and because he is
you know the kind of guy like a Barney
Fife it will shoot himself in the foot
he's kind of a ridiculous figure but to
get rid of him they talked him up to the
White House and say this guy's James
Bond is James Bond and the White House
buys it and then of course because they
don't know any better I mean they'd be
it's not like there's some arch-criminal
running the plumbers it's run by a guy
named Egil Krogh bud crow Egil Krogh
nickname was evil Krogh it was a joke
mmm bud Krogh was an Eagle Scout yeah he
was a sweetheart he shouldn't have been
running hunt and and and Liddy he didn't
know what he was doing yeah
and they there were screw-ups it was a
gang that couldn't shoot straight they
got caught and Nixon was too shy and
awkward and non-confrontational kinda
kind of step in and get control of it
and then it got out of control I think
he also I think Nixon felt and maybe
some of its you know it's not right but
you can almost see where it comes from
he knew that other presidents had been
doing things and he knew that in other
campaigns there had been you know some
dirty trick dirty tricks and he famously
he lost the 1960 election many people
believe that you know some of those
votes in Illinois that went to Jack
Kennedy were released late and that was
a joke Kennedy senior deal and so you
can almost feel Nixon thinking wait a
minute why do I have to be the first
president to call everybody in on the
rug and say you're fired when everyone
does this which is exactly what he
should have done it had been a two-term
president and you're exactly right
he thinks the Kennedys invented dirty
tricks and he exaggerated but he's not
entirely wrong right Bobby Kennedy had a
guy named Paul Corbin working for him
there's a classic Kennedy dirty trick
this is one of my favorite in the 1960
election in the Wisconsin primary which
Kennedy's got a win there's an
Catholic vote there's anti-catholic
feeling and so all the sudden all this
anti-catholic literature starts pouring
into Wisconsin from Minnesota
Kennedy's opponent Hubert Humphrey is
from Minnesota so everybody thinks
Humphrey is trying to poison the well by
sending all this anti-catholic
literature into Wisconsin
it wasn't Humphrey it was Bobby Kennedy
who did it so that Humphrey would be
blamed
pretty Byzantine dirty trick yes it's a
complicated pool shot but it actually
works out and it works yeah and Nixon
studies this right he goes whoa I want
to be able to the Democrats have this
guy named dick tuck this kind of
practical joker
prankster who would you know like turned
the street signs around before the rally
so the crowd would go in the wrong
direction yeah kind of stuff right and
Nixon wanted his own dick tuck and he
wanted to match and surpass the Kennedys
at dirty tricks he exaggerated the
Kennedys capacity for dirty tricks and
he got guys who were a lot less
competent than dick tuck and paid for it
Pat Nixon you write about her in the
book and she's someone who I in your
book she comes to life for me and I have
to admit my image of her was always as
the sort of astronauts wife the frozen
smile to the the ice lady that and and
and someone who was sort of a wax figure
plastic pet the plastic Pat and they
really did have a very intense
complicated relationship but I'll never
forget when she dies and he's just
weeping undone yeah I mean he's not just
crying not just kind of like he's
bawling right he's sobbing he's broken
he's broken and he dies a year later
yeah so like all things Nixon
complicated and those photographs do see
a pet she looks drawn she looks terrible
and I think in the last year of
Watergate they weren't really talking
but Julie writes about how mom and dad
were drinking too much if their
daughters admitting that you can be sure
they were drinking too much and I
noticed that when Nixon decided to
resign
he doesn't tell Patti tells his
secretary rosemary woods to tell Pat how
close is the marriage then right not but
I told my wife I'm resigning the
presidency yeah so what's up send a memo
well but if you read their love letters
there there's real romance and passion
there Nixon was a pat and also I ran a
picture in the book of Pat in the night
from 1953 not the later Pat right Pat's
a knockout and she she's gorgeous she's
as pretty as Jackie Kennedy she's about
ten pounds heavy she's curvy she's
lovely and Nick Nixon one of Nixon's
writers told me
Nixon was like that guy in high school
who couldn't believe his good luck and
that he married the prettiest girl yeah
and Nixon was so determined to woo Pat
that he would I love this drive her on
dates with other men he pursued it for
two years he would drive her drop her
off at parts unbelievable that she's on
a date with someone else he likes her so
much he says all right I'll Drive I'll
Drive look don't you have a good time
you know and you enough cash your kids
have fun you crazy
hotel lobby and then come back and pick
her up and he wore finally wore down and
she said yes and she's supportive she
hated politics but every once in a while
he would want to quit because he and
some of his psychological ease testing
her I I hate I come giving up oh no you
can't so some of it is him kind of
luring but but the point is she stood by
him again and again in tough times and
when he was pulling at and and their
marriage was delicate and brittle there
in Watergate but after he left office he
put the marriage back together again
they were they were close I know from
people that I've talked to their
housekeeper you know they really were
very their Court it's an old-fashioned
marriage they're very kind of courtly
with each other pulling his chair out
and you know making sure napkin is right
so it's kind of sweet and and informal
but it's real you talk about the
drinking and another part of the book
that I find interesting because I read a
lot and we've all heard a lot about
Nixon drinking and one
the halls of the White House especially
during the the end Watergate and AIDS
thinking well he's he's drunk or he's
you know this is really getting bad you
know in the book you feel that he was
just a lightweight drinker it wasn't
that he was throwing back four and five
martinis it's that he could become drunk
or inebriated after one or two drinks
there's a big debate among Nixon
ologists about whether it was a boozer
or not yeah
I'm not actually sure the answer but one
of the complicated things have to do
with the pharmacology of the age in the
1950s when doctors handed out pills they
were some whopper pills now Nixon had a
doctor named hutch Necker and one of my
friends is a fellow scholar named Merlin
Gelman got the medical records and Joe
generously shared them with me Nixon was
prescribed thing called a quenelle which
was a barbiturate based antidepressants
that was so powerful that they took it
off the market after a couple of years
he was given some kind of in feta mean
based upper he was given a sleeping pill
called Seconal that had barbiturates in
it I mean you might as well shoot him
with a gun yeah you know these are very
powerful things I saw in doctor he had
an osteopath named Ryland who kept a
diary and I saw Rylan's diary that I
Island prescribed for Nixon that nixon
couldn't sleep chronic insomniac yes
Ryland prescribes a valium before he
takes the second haul I mean and then
he's having he's having pops was having
a drink or doesn't take much you know
and take much after that a Leonard
garment used to write that Nixon would
call him in the middle of the night
during the 68 campaign and just talk at
him until suddenly there was no more
talk what had happened was they'd given
him a pill on a drink and he would just
pass out pass out now that story
disputed by Dwight Chapin to travel with
Nixon this is so the conflicting aids
verse right right but but Haldeman wrote
that his chief of staff wrote
they would find Nixon sometimes in
coffee shops at 5:00 ago candidate
running for president United States he
being a coffee shop at five o'clock in
the morning after going on walkabouts in
the city Haggard and drawn not having
slept all night he just he just couldn't
sleep you almost feel like you know the
essence of tragedy is that the seed of
the tragedy is at the very beginning you
know and going back to the very
beginning Nixon has this very sad tough
childhood tough dad right tough dad
bully he loses two brothers and when one
of the brothers dies his father makes it
up tuberculosis his father makes it
quite clear that the good one died he
was the good one yeah we lost the good
one and Nixon has to hear that to add to
the irony they would have had the money
for Nixon to go to Harvard to Harvard
but they spent the money on the brother
who had tuberculosis to go to the very
best facility even though he was
certainly gonna die anyway right so
Nixon has all the seeds are there for
this man who is filled with incredible
determination but also incredible
negativity and maybe some kind of
self-loathing and and this one thing
that I got obsessed with was was he
self-aware was Nixon able to see this
inner battle and you know I would ask
people makes him self aware right and
they'd say no Brent Scowcroft said well
I think sometimes he took a peek and but
then I remember asking a James
Schlesinger had been Nixon's secretary
of defense and CIA director and I said
was Nixon self-aware and Schlesinger
said no and then he looked at the window
and he said but who is you know it's a
fair point particularly with great men
because if you're too self-aware
when you're a great man you're not gonna
get anything done you know if you wake
up in the morning kind of ring in your
hands and worrying about your inner
fears and doubts nothing you have to
wake up you know you have to wake up
saying I'm gonna conquer the world so
it's not really a surprise that
Churchill and Lincoln right were
manic-depressives
but that's
of grandiosity and grandeur and I'm
gonna win world war 2 and I'm gonna win
the Civil War followed by what Churchill
called the black dog the black we have
the inevitable flipside of mania the
very downside Nixon was not
manic-depressive that's a different
different problem but he had this kind
of need to be great the sense of destiny
he really thought he was this poor it
was all from the 30 he'd say this is
Nixon Nixon is going to check no you're
Nixon I mean he would he would refer to
himself as Nixon yeah it was a bag he
got some bad advice from Charles de
Gaulle of lagron Charolais you don't
want to take any you don't want a
pattern any of your behavior after
Charles de Gaulle
I don't think law was his very grand
figure and it kind of worked for de
Gaulle the mystery of command and being
distant a remote and Nixon tried to
pattern himself Nixon was bad at being
mysterious and remote he just that
really wasn't him and it sort of worked
badly for him I don't even not sure that
Nixon himself believed it was one of
these things we're trying to persuade
himself late at night I'm gonna be
mysterious and remote well yeah repeat
after me
mister is room I'll write it on right by
right now 50 times these times I'll be
that person
yeah you know you almost feel like what
is the lesson we can learn can we learn
anything from this guy I mean I read
this book and I thought you talked about
Nixon not being self-aware I think that
was the the generation and not just that
generation but I think therapy
self-awareness introspection those are
things that we've allowed ourselves in
the literally in the last 30 years I I
don't think I think people in my parents
generation and the generation preceding
that they're they're almost felt like
there was no time for that
right there was no time for you suck it
up suck it up and keep going and there
was no time you know on the morning of
d-day there was no time to talk to
people about how do you feel about what
you about to get out there and most of
you were gonna die but we have to do
this and get going and I don't want to
hear about it and Nixon wanted to be
that Eisenhower like figure but but
actually by our modern lights needed a
good shrink what what's the lesson from
there
I love to go to teach class and draw
lessons there is no lesson no NIC Sansui
generous you know he's one of a kind
there there's not gonna be another Nixon
we're not never gonna elect a weirdo
like that president United States just
it's not can we
I may have to play this for you a year
and a half yeah yeah that was it man
leave you said that yeah this will go
viral in here all right well we we have
a question from social media if you're
ready for this this is from Benjamin
Carville and he said if modern news and
social media of today was the norm
during Nixon's presidency how do you
think Nixon would have been portrayed
how would he have handled it good
question I don't think Nixon would have
done well with more exposure I mean the
weird part would have come out sooner
people would have made fun of it his
awkwardness imagine his late-night
tweets yeah you know about he's tweeting
it and it's getting out I think he would
have self-destructed early in the game
I mean conceivably people would have
seen some kind of weird authenticity but
I don't really believe that I think
social media would have killed him I
mean you know I this constant bright
light exposure kills off the good and
the bad and discourages people like
Nixon from even trying he was a very
private man in his own way and he would
have not liked the intrusions of Twitter
or you know something like Gawker would
have been just so odious to him he just
he would have hated the internet and he
would have hated the whole thing but to
argue against myself for a second it was
a populist and one thing he would have
liked about modern media is that they
stand up to elitist media and he would
have that piece of it he would have
liked so that instead of the New York
Times and Washington Post and NBC and
CBS you know running everything now we
live in a world where people have blogs
and oh they call out the the New York
Times The Washington Post today they get
it wrong they are called out in
immediately and Nixon would have liked
that popular check on power he would
have gone for that he wouldn't like to
have been the victim of it snow
but he would have enjoyed watching the
New York Times squirm when some bloggers
called him out
the biggest question I'm left with with
Nixon and I've never understood it and
you describe it in the book is he in
when times are tough no one's better but
at the moments in his life of his
greatest achievements he is dark
he's sullen and he's you know in a foul
temper and an ill mood what was what was
that I mean the morning after the
greatest landslide when he should have
at least taken a day and said I am now a
two-term president I've just won the
greatest landslide in American history
he said you're all fired
he'd went to a staff until you're called
- and he fired them all and was in a bad
mood he was that was a that's a very
strange quality it sure is and it wasn't
just then this happening yeah again and
again and again they get to break
through to China they end the Vietnam
War he's always down in the dumps I I
think at some level Nixon was engaged in
this unbelievable existential struggle
against his demons there's very there's
no direct evidence of it it's not like
he's writing notes to himself about his
memoirs covered this all up yeah but I
think judging from the circumstantial
evidence like you know when he goes into
a room he's got to turn on all the
lights he's got to put the you know
carousel oh yeah you know the King and I
on the record Polites noise all of the
up has got to be up suggests that he
fears the darkness you know it's trying
so hard for the light that he must fear
the darkness and you see this at the
latest moment the darkness comes
flooding back in yeah
it's really it's very poignant I did not
expect that I when I picked up the book
and and read it and I don't think I've
thought about Nixon because I remembered
in 1990
three when I got my late-night talk-show
22 years now just a few days ago someone
in the press asked me who would you most
want to interview you know and I said I
think Richard Nixon because he's not
just he's one of the biggest names he's
center stage for such a massive piece of
the 20th century and he's everywhere
he's a cold war figure he's you know
he's a he's not just the president he's
he's vice president for two terms but
he's also even when he's out of office
he's got he's constantly he's Zelig he's
everywhere and he's so controversial and
he's also this great comedic figure and
I thought that's the guy want to talk to
him I think he died about a year into my
show and I remember thinking that's a
guy would have liked to have what a
fascinating person to talk to
I probably would have known gotten
anywhere I would have loved to have seen
that interview yeah it would have really
been interesting yeah he might have done
it he was strange enough he was a
challenge you know he might have thought
this smart young smartass from Harvard
would be yeah it would be a challenge
yeah he might have done it might have
done it yeah well I cannot say enough
good about being Nixon a man divided I
really loved the book and I just think
you can't if you're gonna think about
America 20th century you have to get
some grip on Nixon and I think of all
the books that I've read I think you've
come the closest to cracking him as a
person which is to say you'll never
completely crack it no no they're gonna
be a lot more Nixon books this is just
one of many
yeah but he's endlessly fascinating most
one book I've ever written just cuz he's
so straight so an hour I'll tell you
this what I didn't expect I've read a
bunch of histories where I had the
feeling that I'm eating my oatmeal I
have to I have to do this because this
is good for me and this will help me
understand this book is a is fun to read
it's really fun to read these are great
stories very poignant it's funny it's
sad it's tragic it's the whole thing so
thank being Nixon a man divided Evan
Thomas read this book you'll be glad you
did thank you so much for doing this
this is really fun thank you